the reality is is that it was november
8th
and we hadn't had any kind of
significant rain
it had always rained before
trick-or-treating right i mean right
and now and now we're in these patterns
here where we don't see rain until you
know into november
that morning the wind cranked up and
you know you're kind of waiting like
what's coming next in this particular
case
it was a fire eight miles away throwing
up a
column full of embers and darkest
blackest calm smoke i've ever seen and
then a 40 mile an hour wind
taking that over the top of paradise in
perfect alignment
and dropping it on the town of paradise
and so
it really was the perfect storm
we lost some thousand acres of land
there was multiple fires burning for at
least a week
probably more we just tried to save what
we can save
and help people along the way is about
all we could do
it didn't matter if we had a thousand
fire engines lined up on the ridge that
day
this was going to happen everything
lined up perfectly
that day for this to happen